[Music]
differing themes criticism from the
original writer and an iconic mask what
else could it be but a comic book
adaptation stay tuned to find out the
untold truth of v for vendetta
during the early 80s uk publisher and
editor des skin left marvel uk and
started his own imprint quality
communications in 2004 he told ninth art
that he invited artist david lloyd and
author alan moore to work on a story
that would eventually become b for
vendetta the first chapter appeared in
skin's new anthology warrior moore
wanted to incorporate a lot of themes
including riffs on george orwell aldous
huxley thomas pinchon the prisoner and
many other cultural touchtones each
issue featured a single chapter and the
storyline was organized into three
separate books warrior ran for 26 issues
and v for vendetta ran in every issue
but won the last two chapters of book
two were set to appear in number 27 and
number 28 but they were never published
dc comics picked up the series added
color and released the books as 10
single issues before they were collected
the final issue was published nearly
seven years after the first story
appeared
alan moore made his disdain for the
movie version of the for vendetta clear
during an interview with mtv saying the
comic was specifically about things like
fascism and anarchy those words fascism
and anarchy occur nowhere in the film
it's been turned into a bush-era parable
by people too timid to set a political
satire in their own country according to
infoshop news moore's interest in
anarchism was highly developed grasping
it in its most basic sense not a lack of
order but an absence of leaders
v for vendetta was an experiment in the
understanding that the conditioning of a
fascist state in particular has to be
stripped away before its people can
choose their own way moore's
understanding of this was taking
responsibility for one's own actions as
well as acknowledging that they are part
of a larger group the ending of the film
which is essentially one big protest
with people wearing guy fox masks seems
to confirm the idea that it was less
about the total destruction of a fascist
state to build something anew and more
about the importance of direct action in
a democracy which is at the heart of
liberalism when v dies at the end finch
asks evie his true identity
here is you
and me
he use all of us
v uses a guy fox mask and wears a wig to
conceal his identity his first major act
was destroying the houses of parliament
on november 5th 1997. guy fox was a
catholic conspirator who sought to
destroy parliament by packing it full of
gunpowder and blowing it up he was
arrested before he could carry it out
and his plot became a patriotic rallying
point historically guy fox day was
celebrated to burn fox in effigy which
is where the masks originated morris
averted this idea when he had v
destroying these buildings and david
lloyd made effective use of this frozen
smiling face throughout the book the
film inspired a number of people to don
the mask in various forms of protest
ironically according to the new york
times time warner owns the rights to the
image and prophets with each mask sold
the hacker collective anonymous uses the
guy fox mask as a disguise for its
activities which have included cyber
attacks on the cia kkk church of
scientology and various corporations the
mask was also frequently seen during the
occupy movement and protests in hong
kong protecting identities while
symbolizing protest
v's origin begins in the park hill
resettlement camp where experiments were
performed by a scientist who wanted to
see what would happen when people were
injected with an experimental drug it
killed all of them eventually everyone
except for one patient the man in room
five
though completely insane the survivor
was also a genius and after killing
dozens in his escape he no longer had a
name when he introduced himself he told
people to call him v an identity he took
to the extreme
verily this vicious of verbiage veers
most verbose so let me simply add that
it's my very good honor to meet you and
you may call me v
these headquarters are located under the
defunct victoria underground station one
of only two stations in london that
start with v he is drawn to vaudeville
he uses beethoven's fifth symphony to
drown out a conversation the first five
notes of which spell out v in morse code
every chapter of the comic starts with v
from the introductory the villain to the
concluding valhalla
v quotes from the thomas pinchot novel v
which is about a man obsessed with a
mysterious person known only as v
apart from the divergent themes the main
difference between the film and comic
versions of v for vendetta is the
relationship between v and evie hammond
in the comic evie is a naive 16 year old
with no education in the film evie is an
employee of the british television
network in both cases v rescues her from
vicious fingermen emotionally the comic
version of bee is a kind of surrogate
father for evie but he is also cruel to
her he always does it in a way that he
calculates will help make her his ideal
replacement but he still manipulates her
into helping murder the bishop abandons
her on a street when he knows it is time
for her to live life as an adult and
then kidnaps and tortures her to achieve
the same kind of liberating
transformational experience he had in
the film the relationship between v and
evie is more romantic in nature however
he still kidnaps and tortures her for
similar reasons the political jumble
makes this relationship make a lot less
sense v wants someone morally pure to
take his place someone whose choices
aren't rooted in violence in the film
everyone gets a guy fox mask and evie's
role is far less important
v knows that he's a killer that has
chosen destruction he doesn't see
another way to bring down the fascist
order however it is strongly implied
that it would be all too easy for him to
simply insert himself as a new leader
the last thing he wants v knows that he
has no role in the new world but the
symbol of what v represents is important
that's why he grooms evie to be his
replacement one who isn't stained as a
killer and whose integrity is also
impeccable
beneath this mask there is more than
beneath this mask there is an idea mr
crete here
and ideas are bulletproof it seems
perhaps like a bit of bravado but it is
also true v creates a new persona a new
symbol that now exists outside of
himself he tells evie you must discover
whose face lies behind this mask but you
must never know my face evie realizes he
meant that his actual identity is
irrelevant because it is now her face
behind the mask
in v's carefully designed crusade to
kill or leave comatose everyone who
knows his true identity his second
victim is bishop anthony lillaman who
was present at the larkill concentration
camp where v was imprisoned when evie
volunteers to help v uses her as bait
for the bishop who is secretly a
pedophile she distracts him while v
slips in v uses this as an excuse for a
series of rifts on god and the devil
positioning himself as the latter i
clothe my naked villainy with old odd
ends stolen forth from holy writ and
seem a saint when most i play the devil
in the comics when v reveals himself to
the bishop he says
please allow me to introduce myself i am
a man of wealth and taste that's the
famous first line from the rolling stone
song sympathy for the devil wherein
lucifer recounts history from his
perspective the also tells liliman i'm
the devil and i come to do the devil's
work a similar line was reportedly
spoken by charles denton tex watson jr a
manson family associate on the night of
the sharon tate murders
alan moore was the writer of v for
vendetta and david lloyd was the artist
both had rather divergent feelings about
the film lloyd was supportive of the
film and pleased by the result in
particular he was impressed by the
attention to detail in trying to make
the movie look a lot like the comic
telling ain't it cool news they used the
original graphic novel as storyboards
practically owen patterson the designer
was concerned about getting things
looking exactly like the original
regarding the changes the director made
lloyd thought it turned out well and
said he understood that alterations had
to be made he also disagreed with moore
and thought the film's message and
philosophy stuck to the original source
material lloyd was especially impressed
by the work of adrian biddle the
cinematographer for v for vendetta
telling aina cool news it's really
extraordinary seeing something that
you've created come to life like that
the scene he thought bore the closest
resemblance to the original was when
evie emerges from her jail realizes that
v has been her torturer and the moment
between them that followed for lloyd
drawing something as close to real life
in the comics was important to him
adding that much of the film felt
faithful to his original art and saying
i think that speaks volumes to me about
the dedication of the filmmakers to the
original work alan moore's disdain for
all of the film adaptations of his
comics is well known he rejects the very
concept of tv or film adaptations saying
in an interview with ian winterton
just because something worked as a comic
book that didn't mean you should make it
into a film or a television series or a
whole franchise
moore's reaction to his works being
adapted has always been twofold removing
his name from the film and distributing
any money made to the artists who worked
on it however his requests were
frequently ignored moore explained that
he got a phone call from one of the
wachowskis and politely told her that he
quote didn't want anything to do with
the v for vendetta film
moore went on to say a friend had told
him that in the press producer joel
silver had claimed that moore was
excited about the film and was working
directly with the wachowskis
more riley noted that the studio
respected his request to not get paid
but went on to add the side of the deal
where i actually got what i wanted which
was utter non-involvement with these
films that somehow didn't seem to have
worked out in discussing writing v for
vendetta alan moore specifically talked
about fleshing out every character even
the villains saying in an interview with
blather.net
i was very pleased with the
characterizations in v for vendetta
there's quite a variety of characters in
there and they've all got very
distinctive characteristics
that was true of even the most
despicable characters which was
important to moore because they felt
emotionally credible to him he thought
writing about fascists as stereotypical
villains would do little to establish
just how commonplace and easy it is for
fascism to arise adding whereas in fact
fascists are people who work in
factories probably are nice to their
kids it's just that they're fascists
they're just ordinary they're the same
as everybody else except for the fact
that they're fascists
v for vendetta was director james
mctigue's first film at the helm after
assisting the wachowskis with the matrix
franchise and although it's quite
faithful in many respects that doesn't
mean the comics were sacrosanct to the
filmmakers
in fact as mctigue recalled to the
website little white lies
we decided to do a rewrite because the
original script was very unwieldy and
slavish to the graphic novel regarding
the film's legacy mcteig mused
it has come to mean something different
now i'm glad there's a lot of people who
understood the message of the movie in
the way that it had its part in arab
spring occupy wall street the hong kong
protests the notion that irwi is strong
and we can't control everything
he said that the v masks get
misappropriated at times noting that he
saw a lot of them at the capitol
building riot on january 6 2021 but he
recognizes that it's the risk every
creator takes once you put a piece of
art out into the world it's no longer
yours people find meaning in the way
they want to v is one of those films and
i'm happy for that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book adaptations are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one